Amsterdam the day after the inauguration
there's little trace of the festivities
to all appearances may 1st is a normal
working day for the Dutch in the daily
papers the royal succession is the top
story
Korda hoarder an expert on the dutch
royals scans the photos and headlines
his take on the big day his countrymen
really enjoyed the parties
beautiful on sundays in da what's
typically Dutch about this day isn't
what happened in the church or the
palace it's the craziness of the people
dancing in the streets having fun start
the domes and please here mark the
morning of April the 30th like most of
the Dutch Laurent a store g had started
partying the night before few turned out
to watch Queen Beatrix his abdication
live Lauren des story was the only one
of his friends to keep the appointment
for the public viewing I think she was
very professional I'd lovely put it that
way not always maybe the most as a
warm-hearted person but really she knew
what she wanted and she was very
professional what she did the Queen may
be history but the Queen's day wasn't
yet the people of Amsterdam began
turning out around noon Laurens friends
finally arrived and he made some
last-second touch-ups to his outfit I
just bought ads I want to have some
extra Suarez but a lot of people they
took on a t-shirt or they don't judge
dress anything it doesn't really matter
that's just I think the concept let's do
a bit crazy the party wing goes on most
of Lauren's friends didn't feel like
fighting the crowds they took to the
water one of them had organized a little
boat for a tour of the canals and they
weren't the only ones
in Amsterdam Queen state is celebrated
on land and on the water
it's a bit of a tradition just like you
have next to selling your wares next to
the streets you also see a lot of people
on the boats and it's just one big party
you can hear it around you the music on
the boats and we don't have a
destination we're just traveling around
a bit and just having fun
many of the hundreds of thousands on
Amsterdam streets were more interested
in having a good time than in seeing the
royal ceremonies to be honest this
morning I had a slight hangover and I
missed the ceremony but the Queen's
night was amazing and I know the new
king he will be fine and we celebrated
the rest of the day and the rest of his
career the Dutch took their new king
along to the parties throughout the day
learned in his friends move from Party
to party by boat I cannot describe it
it's also I've been around the world but
definitely this is a party that's unique
I would say not too far away from all
the revelry the official ceremonies are
gradually drawing to an end
the new monarchs hear the song that was
composed especially for them Laurent and
his friends avoid the crowd and prefer
to watch it all on the big screen
they're not too keen on the Kings song
anyway in the evening after the Royal
boat trip the Dutch public start to head
home - what can they expect from their
new monarch IV well carotid vein for
dementia he wants to be there for the
people I think that's what we'll see
from him as king he's admitted to making
mistakes and expects to make more but
people have to learn from mistakes and
he admits it his mother on the other
hand was a perfectionist she never spoke
about mistakes he does and I think
that's refreshing
a new king also means a new date for the
next party starting next year people
will celebrate April the 27th as Kings
day the birthday of vilom Alexander